nouvelle ronde de saint-just trésorier
du rassemblement national et président
du groupe rassemblement à nationale en
ile de france
bonsoir va le rendre saint-just merci à
d'être avec nous sur rt france bonsoir
et merci d'être là marine le pen a parlé
d'un islamisme qui nous mène la guerre
vous êtes d'accord avec ces propos oui
ce sont des propos parfaitement adapté à
la situation
on peut penser à ce qui s'est passé et
se passe encore maintenant au liban et
ce qui se passe en israël quand on est
vraiment une situation de guerre va
supporter en france que des personnes
comme ce processus soit décapité
décapité pour des raisons de protection
de la liberté d'expression ou d'abus la
liberté ça peut pas exister il faut que
l'on création avec toute la violence
nécessaire
c'est sûr vous dites il faut réagir avec
la violence nécessaire jusqu'à présent
vous pensez les discours n'ont pas suffi
à essayer d'endiguer justement à ce
fléau
non seulement les discours n'ont pas
réussi mais il faut spécialement pointé
du doigt
évidemment la responsabilité intuilab de
l'assassin mais la responsabilité
immense dans ses actes des politiciens
qui nous gouvernent depuis des années et
qui ont encouragé une ration incontrôlée
et des politiciens et des intellectuels
nous ont seriné sur le culturalisme
culturalisme et surtout ceux qui nous
ont toujours nous qui des mentions cette
immigration incontrôlée des nations
marque sur notre territoire depuis des
années est une pré tête de 2,2 de
raciste de 2,2 de phase i sur toutes les
insultes possible nous ont traînés
devant les tribunaux chronologie des
politiques et des politiques
particulièrement juste et toucher
jenlain sont responsables les horreurs
qui arrive aujourd'hui voilà nous sommes
dont
en guerre avec les terroristes
islamistes avec les égorgeurs qui
décapite heures mais nous sommes en
guerre aussi contre ces politiciens et
ses intellectuels
il faut qu'il fasse un jacquard examen
de conscience et qu'ils se taisent et
qu'il y laisse les personnes
responsables
en france les personnes responsables
politiquement trahir ceux qui ont vraie
conscience comme la situation comment
agir alors va le rendre saint-just
on sait que les services de
renseignement sont plutôt efficace
comment agir contre ce type d'individu
série durant six mois ne sont absolument
pas efficace absolument pas efficace
mais je ne leur jette pas la pierre
c'est comme les services de gendarmerie
ils n'ont pas d'instructions des
instructions contraires en fait on rien
pas de vagues
sinon nous allons être accusé de racisme
parce qu'il s'agit ça parce qu'il s'agit
du liban c'est comme ça depuis 20 ans 30
ans c'est eux ce sont ces gens là tant
d'années ces instructions qui n'ont pas
donné ses instructions à toutes les
forces de répression et d'autorité en
france
agir de cette façon là à ccc dans des
services de renseignement en france
n'ont pas les moyens de travailler parce
qu'ils n'ont pas
l'instruction se tuent nos frères c'est
en premier lieu sachez quand même
presque le plus facile faire respecter
de façon à plus nécessaire possible des
règles de la laïcité ne pas tolérer la
moindre entend ce à la halle aux règles
de la laïcité au risque d'empiéter sur
les libertés individuelles
on risque de dja les libertés 85 pts et
ceux qui viennent la laïcité française
ceux qui veulent par exemple séparatisme
ceux qui veulent avoir des horaires
particuliers dans les piscines ceux qui
refusent parce que tout ça c'est que
c'était d'un tout ça mène c'est toute sa
teinte au chili il ya très peu de
différence il ne faut pas te les risques
il faut montrer que l'état français la
république française affronte notamment
jamais cela ensuite les terroristes même
consul et la façon d'un cul
la plus chère mme les plus lourds la
façon de faire a dit qu'arsenal moi
j'aurais camou rétablissement de la
peine de mort pour ceux ayant des
terroristes nos jours d'itt a été tué
par la police il a appliqué la peine
d'avoir à la victime il a dicté par la
position de ceux qui sont arrêtés ils
auraient peut-être car est il aurait
réclamé au rétablissement à peine deux
grands pôles il faut déchoir il faut
excuser toutes les personnes qui n'ont
pas assez française et qui sont proches
qui se réclamerait de cet islamisme
radical par des nichoirs de leurs
meubles
que faire des nationaux qui auront fait
de la prison de le déchoir de la
nationalité française et les renvoyer
dans leur pays d'origine
il ya des dizaines et des dizaines de
personnes qui dans ce sens dans ce cas
la france elle part en trempant la
synthèse de nos gouvernants de nos
administrations
il faudra retirer la française il faut
immédiatement après éventuellement à ses
jours en prison
s'ils ont commis des délits ou des
crimes et ils sont montrés il faut
montrer la fermeté la sévérité la très
grande sévérité
l'absence totale de tolérance à l'égard
de la cac qui en paient le prix de la
mollesse et de la 20 vols et ont pas les
gouvernants français sopra c'est pas
monsieur macron c'est pas les hauts
fonctionnaires
ce sont les français c'est ce professeur
typique de d'indicés de la grande
banlieue parisienne qui vient d'être
décapités hall a tranché la tête ce qui
doit être fait des morts des plus
horribles que l'on connaisse voilà vous
êtes un homme politique d'île de france
on a entendu sur notre antenne un
professeur d'histoire de
seine-saint-denis justement nous parler
du fait que ça fait longtemps qu'ils
alertait aussi sur certains
comportements qui ne sont pas forcément
en adéquation avec la laïcité
que faut-il faire c'est un problème en
tout cas qui semble assez récurrent dans
certains endroits il faut supporter ces
comportements évidemment que un certain
nombre de professeurs
qui sont en première ligne et c'est le
char de la république qui existent
encore et qui sont en première les
invertis depuis très très longtemps en
disant voilà ce qui se passe il ya des
islamistes en qui ce qui existe dans les
banlieues notamment de france et dans
les collèges et lycées de france
il fallait réagir très violente il ya
très longtemps on a toujours lui le
politicien les intellectuels dont ils et
comment réagir
il nous allons bien connaître des arcs
des discriminations des actes de racisme
ne pouvons pas c'est contraire à ce que
nous pensons et en plus nous avons peur
ne le sent pas nous avons qu ils ont en
plus tous ce sont des temps car si
certains il faut dire que l'algérie est
extrême de l'autre côté il faut pas
avoir peur sinon on va tous et être
portées en revenant sur les faits ce
professeur a à montrer donc ces
caricatures dans un but pédagogique
semble-t-il beaucoup de parents s'en
sont indignés il ya même eu beaucoup de
des chances sur les réseaux sociaux
suite à ce cours est ce que vous pensez
que c'est ce qui a pu exacerbée en tout
cas et a mené cet individu à agir chez
son islamisme qu'il y at il la conduit à
agir c'est pas la latitude qu'en
sera-t-il du professeur je pense qu'il
avait des élèves des quand même un
certain âge devant lui et faire un cours
dans le cadre de l'éducation civique un
cours sur la liberté d'expression en
france en prenant pour exemple justement
ces caricatures de mahomet dans charlie
hebdo
il n'y a pas plus yaka ya pas meilleur
comme cours ya pas plus petits tactique
il a eu raison de le faire sécher fera
tant qu'homme cours et la plus chère
comprendre aux élèves ce que ce qu'est
la liberté d'expression aussi ce que
sont les atteintes à l'éducation
ce professeur maintenant on peut le
considérer comme sens de héron non
seulement d'avoir chez secours et après
ce qui est arrivé des conséquences qu'il
a subie dans sa chair le professeur qui
a même pris soin de à entendre aussi ce
parent d'élève
on a entendu de faire sortir les élèves
musulmans pour ne pas justement les
froisser est ce que c'est une attitude
en cours d'histoire en france le vrai
musulman
il n'y a pas des logements dans une
classe de la république française y'a
pas dsk telle il n ya pas d vous disent
qu'il ya des élèves de nationalité
française qu'ils apprennent l'éducation
civique histoire la géographie dispensés
par l'éducation nationale française
voilà et s'ils sont pas contents eh ben
il dit vont voir ses parents en arabie
saoudite c'est différent est bon alors
il a en plus pris cette précaution lui
fait ressortir et moi ça passe ou ça n'a
pas suffi c'est peut-être ce qui a
provoqué aussi au temps de réaction
que pensez-vous du chef de l'état ce
soir qui s'est rendu sur place c'est
assez inhabituel
qu'attendez vous de ce chef de l'état
rien rien rien et lé shoz place comme il
le fait toujours contient un événement
de ce genre d attrait ce silence total
de calme plat et je macro comme monsieur
hollande comme monsieur sarkozy et ses
prédécesseurs n'ont jamais pris la
moindre mesure et akale contre ses sept
jeux dracé drame épouvantable qui nous
arrive et c'est ambiance absolument
insupportable
ils n'ont jamais pris la moindre jeu au
contraire au contraire ils ont tous été
des adeptes de deudeuches pseudo
antiraciste 27
les adeptes de ce multiculturalisme ils
ont favorisé tout ça je n'attends rien
de se battre on attend est loin des
couleurs de moi je m'accroche
lui et ses prédécesseurs ont montré non
seulement leur incapacité mehdorn aussi
8 et leur nationalité et ils ont une
grande part de responsabilité dans ce
qui arrive
merci valence de 200 juste d'avoir
répondu ce soir en direct à nos
questions sur rt france